would you call yourself a catholic
or you don't give yourself a label at
all no i wouldn't call myself a catholic
but i definitely
pray the rosary okay you also mentioned
that
hey when you were younger you went to
different religious institutions they
weren't
for you and you thought perhaps religion
the dogmatic side
wasn't for you then i was thinking well
that's a common
feeling for quite a few people they
maybe try one church
two or three and then they
say this is not for me i don't like
these people or i don't like what's
being said
and then they lose this communal aspect
of religion
and you could be an independent
christian like uh like kierkegaard
but it's helpful to have a community
around you
so what would you suggest to those
people who don't who think that religion
is not for them because they've tried it
a couple times
but haven't found the right one and they
think there is no right one
the right one is me maybe if first of
all it might be just me like i'm an
atheist
or it might be just me and my personal
relationship to god and that's all
the problem is with that is you can have
a personal relationship with god or you
can
have a personal relationship with a
higher power of your choosing if you're
an atheist
it doesn't matter it's just it's not you
you know it's your community or it's or
it's nature or something
is is uh inspiring you but
service is a lot of service has is
service is really what is necessary
to receive the benefits
of your relationship with your higher
power
so you have to give it away
without being thanked so it isn't a
it isn't something you're doing for
money it isn't something that you're
doing
for accolades it's you're
doing it because
you're you want to fill yourself with
god
and so the service is is what's
necessary
and when you say service this has
nothing to do with a group of people it
has nothing to do with an institution
because it has nothing to do with an
institution but it has to do with people
service service to other people to
others
to serve others yeah
helping to serve others is what is
necessary
to have a
spiritual experience a full spiritual
experience